marseillais david singer qui a été ici à
quelques heures est en route vers les
états unis à la nasa se son port
d'attaché derrière moi c'est qu'elle
elle de l'associu sa capture vous voyez
son bouclier thermale est complètement
calciné c'est ce qui se produit car la
teillouse traverse les couches de
l'atmosphère terrestre
mais sinon ça a été un atterrissage
parfait regarder elle est atterri à la
verticale on a pu en sortir les
astronautes sans aucun problème
astronautes qui évidemment doivent
composer avec les forces de la gravité
dès leur retour sur terre le premier
était le russe oleg conad en cours qui
est sorti ensuite le déclin en pleine
forme et le canadien en troisième david
saint jacques qui il faut le dire subi
plusieurs malaises à sa sortie de la ciu
c'est complètement normal ça dépend des
astronautes il a dû récupérer dans une
tente médicale qui a été dirigé derrière
nous mais on a pu lui parler est une
heure et demie après l'atterrissage
il dit qu'il est littéralement tombé du
ciel ce matin on peut l'écouter revenir
tombé du ciel tellement tombé du ciel
une fois qu on se convainc que c'est pas
dangereux typhon le bain d'abord nous
sommes chanceux d'être venu mais ça peut
nous aider
puis mais je suis sûr ce qui me surprend
c'est l'audace font ici c'est super
comme il l'a dit il a eu beaucoup de
nausée il est étourdi mais des fois
c'est une question d'heure avant qu'on
puisse retrouver une certaine forme
sinon eh ben si la fin de sa mission les
prochaines semaines seront cruciales
pour étudier les effets de l'apesanteur
sur le corps humain il était d'ailleurs
médecin à bord il a servi de cobaye pour
plusieurs exercices et plusieurs tests
scientifiques et sinon c'est important
qu'on le dit il on est ici au kazakhstan
dans les steppes où la cei aux atterri
depuis des décennies mais c'est
peut-être la dernière fois qu'un
astronaute canadien décolle et atterrit
à bord d'une soyouz faudra attendre des
années c'est pas tous les ans les
astronautes canadiens s'envole vers
l'espace ça pour être 7 8 9 10 ans on
sait pas et il ya de bonnes chances avec
la technologie qui avance rapidement et
les tests qui sont concluants que le
prochain astronaute canadien s'envole et
atterrissent à voir d'une dé nouvelle
génération de fusées pour l'instant la
seule ue est encore le seul taxi qui
fait l'aller-retour vers l'espace et on
a pu voir aujourd'hui un atterrissage
spectaculaire mérite
il cite avoir altéré sco radio canada au
kazakhstan